um okay first of all I have to say that
um Demian Bichir who's here tonight I
hope you still here was my first casting
choice for my film and obviously I
didn't get him but I think we reached
out to ease the agent but didn't work
out but so I'm very honored that he was
here tonight it's kind of a full circle
anyway I have so many things to say so
I'm gonna and lots of names to drop so
I'm gonna try and be really fast first
of all congrats to all the other winners
your films are great and you know
narrative section you lean and quiola
congrats I want to thank the academy for
giving me this opportunity and opening
up lots of perspective for us I want to
thank AFI and all the faculty and staff
there for their help and support through
this process and in particular I want to
thank peter markham Brian Donnelly Mary
canteen Kevin Jones ng walk I want to
thank my amazing cast max Laura Roberto
Darren aldo laura is here tonight and of
course my two leads benahavis and gina
rodriguez who I can't think enough for
being part of this project with me I
also need to thank and want to thank my
incredible team and they're all here
tonight and thank you so much and I love
you all very very much brett meyer my
producer ashrita cam at my production
designer Frances Miller my editor and
Justin Kane my amazing DP I love you all
I said that already and also I want to
thank all my friends my family all my
friends who i think are here tonight and
who I've met here since I've been in the
US and who I really who helped me
throughout these three years here Mike
Ludo Carolina Beth furnace thank you so
much for dealing with me all the
Mexicans they know who they are malo
ticket Jago santiago and garrus thanks
guys and bill thanks for believing my
film and last but not least thanks to my
parents who are came all the way from
friends today to support me I'm sorry I
only got bronze but hopefully do you
next time I'll difficult thank you I
want to thank the academy for inviting
me to be a part of this wonderful event
congratulations to all the winners can't
wait to see what you do next